اخبار العلم باجاز من غرفه اخبار الجزيره
مرحبا بكم اتساع الاحتجاجات في فرنسا على
مقتل شاب برصاص الشرطه الى مدن خارج باريس
الحكومه نشرت 40 الف شرطي للمظاهرات
والسلطات القضائيه تحقق مع المشتبه به
بتهمه القتل العمد في حين اكد رئيس
الفرنسي ان اعمال العنف غير مبرره
مع انتهاء هدنه وقف اطلاق النار اشتباكات
في مناطق بالعاصمه الخرطوم والجيش
السوداني يشن غارات على مواقع للدعم
السريع ويقول انه بدا عمليات في الخرطوم
واندرمان وفي دارفور اتفاق على وقف لاطلاق
النار في ولايه الشمال بموافقه كل الاطراف
الكريم يقول انه لا معلومات لديه بشان
مكان وجود رئيس
لجنه الدفاع بالدمى يقول ان قوه فاغنر لن
تشارك في حرب اوكرانيا بعد رفضها توقيع
عقد مع وزاره الدفاع بينما نفى مصدر
بالوزاره اعتقال نائب قائد العمليه
العسكريه الخاصه
في اول ايام التشريق الثلاثه التي تلي يوم
عيد الاضحى حجاج بيت الله الحرام يتوجهون
الى منطقه الجمرات ويرمون الجمرات الثلاث
مبتدئين بالصغرى ثم الوسطى الكبرى ويبيتون
ليالي التشريق في منها الى اللقاء